now many of you know that Democrats
today are easily offended they demand
that the rest of America bow down at the
altar of political correctness the rules
of which only they determine now last
year they feigned horror when Trump and
his supporters blasted left-wing
activists who were harassing
conservatives one word in particular
triggered them oh you're not gonna use
the my word oh let me move past the in
word Republicans are trying to paint
Democrats as an angry mob you call
people mobs because they are exercising
their constitutional right is just
beyond the pale beyond the pale was this
beyond the pale dawn a shocking scene
today on Capitol Hill one that some
Democrats say resembled a mob quite
honestly it looked like a mob scene our
Republican colleagues who frankly acted
like a mob describing conservatives the
word mob is the least objectionable of
the slander rush referred to it at the
end of Hannity show that the left
routinely uses with impunity against
Republicans white supremacist xenophobes
misogynist etc etc etc no evidence
needed now the moment I heard them
caterwauling about Trump's use of the
word lynching to describe the ongoing
impeachment Star Chamber
I knew the Democrats would once again
get caught with egg on their faces
Biden remember dutifully fell in line
with the language police saying Trump
was despicable and abhorrent for using
the word but then this surfaced even if
the president should be impeached
history is going to question whether or
not this was just a partisan lynching
oops
well Democrats have lost all sense of
perspective and apparently even their
own memory as they try to out metal one
another in the hate Trump Olympics they
have to oppose everything Trump is for
and everything he does even if that
means
contradicting their own views on tone
and key points key substance
now liberals clutch their pearls when
conservatives do something and yet they
make endless excuses for Democrats when
they do the exact same thing now what
better example than the blackface
controversy woke liberals would and do
condemn as racist anyone who wants war
an Indian headdress let alone a costume
with blackface but now we know that they
really don't care about these cultural
offenses since two men are still in
office Democrats could not risk the
political fallout in Virginia coming up
on an election year try to ditch Ralph
Northam and heck Obama even endorsed his
good friend Justin Trudeau if there are
other far more damaging ways in which
the Democrats pretzel like opposition a
trump has manifest itself liberals
started the Free Speech Movement
remember in California fifty years ago
anti-war demonstrations on college
campuses they captivated the nation it
was about more speech not less well I'm
actually not happy to report that today
the left coast is probably the most
inhospitable place for free and
unfettered speech in the country and now
University speech codes are stifling
open and rigorous debate on most
campuses meanwhile only a handful of
real liberals speak out in defense of
ideological diversity their Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg appeared on
Capitol Hill yesterday and he was mugged
by the anti-free speech mob so you won't
take down lies or you will take down
lies so I think it's just a pretty
simple yes or no in a democracy I
believe that people should be able to
see for themselves what politicians that
they may or may not vote for if you
won't take it I'd wager that her truth
is probably different from your truth
but the bottom line is she wants to ban
the stuff she disagrees with ultimately
very illiberal and what about the
presumption of innocence now it's a key
pillar of our legal system right it's a
it's a little jarring when a party
get support from groups like the ACLU
forgets about innocent until proven
guilty especially when there's a juicy
political or judicial opponent to be
smeared which is exactly of course what
happened when Democrats without evidence
tarred Brett Kavanaugh as a sex abuser
and even a gang rapist
and now the left is trying to pull the
same routine on Trump by drastically
lowering the bar for high crimes and
misdemeanors to impeach him so what's
Trump's high crime no a quid pro quo
that never happened it's not in the
transcript of the zolensky call we know
it but the Democrats have seized on the
flip boneheaded comment by trumps acting
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney as key
evidence they're gonna put that
apparently in an article of impeachment
and the party that once believed in
openness and transparency well that's
now totally fine with keeping key
witnesses behind closed doors that way
they control the narrative via selective
leaks to their ideological paramours in
the press we have to impeach this
president I support impeachment I don't
really think this impeachment process
won't take very long
I want to push him out of the White
House to preserve our Constitution our
democracy our basic integrity he should
be impeached the Senators were sitting
senators they're already saying removal
they haven't even seen the evidence put
on in the Senate Senate you see my point
presumption of innocence open and fair
process and of course that's all very
different from the impeachment standard
than the one the same Democrats held
back when Clinton faced Hill Republicans
Republicans in the House are paralyzed
with hatred of President Clinton they
are telling us that our votes don't
count and that the election must be set
aside the American people don't think
that they have made a mistake by
electing Bill Clinton and we in Congress
had better be very careful before we
upset their decision but that was then
and this is now the party that once
claimed to be the champion of
blue-collar workers now offers them
nothing except socialism and in
Trump era 3.5% unemployment and rising
wages that's not going to fly the party
that once thought we should renegotiate
and after remember Obama's promise to do
that they won't pass the u.s. MCA only
because it means a victory for Trump the
party that was once anti-war rails
against Trump's bringing our troops home
home from deployments that were supposed
to last for months not for years the
Democrats are just only too happy to
forsake formerly core issues and beliefs
if they believe it will bring down
Donald Trump but their mask is finally
slipping and the masquerade officially
ends November 2020 and that's the angle